I mean I really look at it see this just
spin it off into a franchise why you cry
of assault anybody knows me since I've
been in the business knows that is
always been my dream to fake mustache
with nobody ever gave me the opportunity
so I wanted to think you know
back and it's just hope it up surfer you
know making this a reality for me how
much do these cost these probably got
more expensive than you think
none of my uglies took the time to
educate me about mustache prices so I
thought this was five I mean I really
see this just spinning off into a
franchise of his own and there just
becomes kind of a multi-faceted
entertainment beast making appearances
in Marvel movies full house reboot logic
songs easy songs and just really doing
the whole gamut
ten years mismo I'm definitely doing
skin lightening cream commercials in
Thailand I go to Thailand and say hey
you don't want to be like me do you then
use this [ __ ] keep hey use this use this
skin cream it's called the effects of
colonialism
[Music]
[Music]
please grab my hair
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know
[Music]
you didn't wanna talk to me but never
beats our [ __ ]
me
[Music]
and it's now down go somewhere I must
bed near my mustache sitting in a
rocking chair to the little monsters
like a villain
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
intergeneration other south
in fact knowledge buddy
yeah I mean this seems legit I think
you'd be felt I think yeah this is legit
yeah everything that anybody has ever
done in the music business has gone
smoothly forever
nobody ever regretted anything they
signed in the music business 20 years
later and never argued about it and
what I'm gonna be on flat TV in five
years
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh I've split but now but very strong
sorry about this button
[Music]
you rotten [ __ ] y'all are
terrible at basketball look at this [ __ ]
no [ __ ] my buzz up man
this isn't that good vibes look at it
why are you crying
I should be crying you guys hit the crap
out cuz you didn't have to watch that
[ __ ] I have to sit here and watch you as
artists I'm uh I'm a servant first to
the to the script why are you crying I
should be crying why are you crying the
[ __ ] you crying about I'm saying who are
you who is he
I'm a servant to the artform
just keep the bat there's this basket
repellant was this its disappoint
repeller Oh put this on and so I can't
school [ __ ] huh
I can't school [ __ ] with this huh huh
huh got me out here looking like a fraud
bah
this ain't even real and so I just tried
this is already a river that is moving
without me and I just try to go with
okay okay okay me okay make a layup good
look nope shut still huh help it move
along maybe a little faster and made me
with surround sound
surround sound I still don't know who
you are
[Music]
second half right now but y'all never be
able to play basketball here for free
again and that's fast
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can do that by myself